Okay, whatever that is. Way to focus on the completely relevant
point. Again, I just I don't think it's cuz she's not stupid
and I think that that kind of undermines the negativity. If she
was as if she was like Darius and clearly very stupid, I would
be thinking differently. >> Like that's your right. >> It's
not about being blind. It's that she has so many other people
that were far more normal to speak to in the Why didn't she just
speak to Lykan? Why didn't she speak to like anyone else but
President Sunday? Why is she putting stuff in a group chat? Why
is she talking to Destiny? Rules about letting children and women
off of ships first or it was just mostly men that survived. We
had these things in place because you already don't care. So,
we got to put these things in place to make you care. >> I
retweeted I retweeted what's his name here. I retweeted Howling
Mutant. How the Howling Mutant tweet was so funny. Uh, the urge
to bully Will Stantil is so ingrained in the human spirit that
the first thing art the first artificial intelligence gain sent
you two nights ago and immediately tried to rword him.
Jesus, the stream is delayed from kick lame. Uh, it shouldn't
be. You should be able to refresh and catch it back up on Twitch,
I think. Should be fine. And then this robot is trained to Will
Stansel. Dude, there's just so many memes that are coming out
about the Will Stansel stuff. Why do people hate this guy so
much? He's super he's hyper annoying on Twitter to the point
that this is like um there's like a universal dislike of Will
Stansel on Twitter that is very reminiscent of the universal
dislike of Mitch Jones. I think I talked about something last
night. I can't remember even the context, but it's like, dude,
oh, it was I was talking to him about the OTK Msk stuff, and
it's so funny that like a lot of people have kind of disliked
Msk for a long time, and now it's like all coming apart. And
I think we're speculating on why like what might get leaked.
We even thought it might be uh Msk is like abusive or something.
He's like abusing Emiru or something. I'm like, yeah, that could
that could track. It's like technically that whole thing with
Mitch that was like psychotic on Miskf's part to like pull over
and beat the out of this guy. That was like kind of actually
psychotic. He just got lucky that it was Mitch Jones. If that
was any other human being on planet Earth, if that was any other
human being on planet Earth, everybody be like, "Whoa, Misk needs
to be charged. This is crazy." But he like got out of his car
and beat the [__] out of M Mitch Jones. And everybody
was like, "You know what? >> I did feel bad for him for
that.
>> I mean, I don't dis I've never disliked Mitch, right?
But I understand what other people do. I I don't know. I guess
>> hold on a second. You got an Ellie tweet here that got
linked. I don't know if I want to watch this or not. It's Destiny
clip. I don't like platforming come vampire, but uh who is Mitch
Jones? Mitch Jones is a World of Warcraft streamer who is kind
of a weirdo and kind of like cries and self victimizes a lot
and everybody was kind of done with. He's just always depressed.
He's always mopey. He's always like, "I can do it, guys. I really
can." And then he streams for like two days and then doesn't
do anything for a month. It's But he is like a good World of
Warcraft player and he is like an entertaining streamer once
he streams. But he just um he just doesn't stream. Oh, also yeah,
he's like hot and gets like hot women and that's the other thing
is he always has like a really hot girlfriend or something. So
he's like this guy who literally is so disgusting. He like in
bottles, but he's always got a hot girlfriend and is always super
>> I think he's done that in quite a while. But yes, that
was not a great period. That was gross. >> You know, before
Miskip became a streamer, he actually made a good video called
Who is Mitch Jones? Oh, did he really? I don't believe that's
true. I believe that Mera drinking the bottle. I think that is
actually played up for stream, but I'd have to consult Zezy.
Zezy would know for sure. Okay, hold on. Give me a second. We're
going to decide. Are we going to check out this clip? Buzzle
linked. Yeah, it it's an Ellie clip. Ellie's funny. We like Ellie
here. All right. This is both bizarre and kind of inhuman.
Wait, what is it going to be? First of all, it was a huge holiday.
>> Also, no offense as a kid myself, kids. All right, listen.
Kids dying is tragic. Sure, but it's not magically infinitely
more tragic than like 20 or 30year-olds dying. The what? Like,
yeah, this is like uh this is like a performative denial of shared
humanity. Like all even shared like animal kingdom heritage.
Like every normal human being in the animal kingdom, every normal,
sorry, animal in the animal kingdom has like an intrinsic an
intrinsic desire to protect and help children, right? Like aside
from, you know, I'm going to eat these. I'm going to eat your
young or something. But like I'm saying there's like a thing
that humans have that I think every animal's built in. Like when
babies look young, they're like, "Oh, this is so cute. I have
to protect it." Right? I'm I should maybe say mammal. Might be
mamlon. I'm not sure. But there's this like baby mammals are
like super cute to us. >> He said that himself, right?
He said this before when he spoke about babies. He's been like
very
vocal about being like, "Oh, they're so cute." or whatever. So,
he's just like changed his tune now, I guess. >> Oh, maybe.
>> I don't know. Weird. >> Maybe. Yeah. Sorry. I
I should have said uh I should have said mammals. I think it's
mammals that have this or Yeah, I think it's mammals. I should
have actually specified because I do think birds are not the
same. Anyway, this is just like it's just weird. It's weird to
do this. It's like a weird Oh, I'm like a logic bro. Logically,
there's just no reason to be more upset about a child dying than
an adult dying. Actually, >> Ruben donated $3. >> Why
is everyone hating on birds?
>> I don't know, man. Remember when Harambe wanted to help
a child? Wait, didn't Harambe like not kill that child? You think
if an adult jumps into like drops into that cage that's going
to have like a great time with that gorilla? I feel like Harambe
was actually trying to protect the child, weren't they? They
did drag the child around, but I think gorillas do that with
their young already, do they not?
>> Yeah. Yeah. I think that's actually eat a lot of animals
will eat their babies under certain conditions if they're stressed
or how it's not like >> Sure. Sure. Sure. A lot of mammals.
>> A lot of mammals. I've I've changed it to mammals because
I think that's more >> Yeah, mammals. You probably are
young. >> probably are. Oh, cats are gross. >> No,
like a lot of animals will if they're like stressed.
>> It's like not normal, but like it happens. Yeah. >> Uh,
bro, it is logically worse when a child dies. It's societal investment
that never gets to pay off. We might lose resources on net when
a child dies. When an adult dies, at least they might have provided
resources, enough resources to be a net positive. Oh, I guess
if you want to I don't know why you have to take utilitarian
view on it. You just be like, "Oh, kids dying is intrinsically
like sad."
>> Like more intrinsically sad than when adults die, but
>> it's like they didn't even get a chance, right? They
just either like kids with cancer, it's like a horrible and then
death is like, "Oh, they didn't even get a chance to just enjoy
life for a little bit. It feels worse, right?"
>> Yeah. Or just a huge holiday. >> Also, no offense
as a kid myself, kids. All right. Listen, kids dying is tragic.
Sure, but it's not magically infinitely more tragic than like
20 or 30 year olds dying. The what? Like, yeah, children dying
is sad, okay? Some children are as All right, they are. It's
not like every single child is like this innocent beacon of pure.
Okay, some >> this is this is actually like straining into
something actually insane.
>> Oh, no.
These were like little kids. Most of the kids that died in the
floods, right, were little kids because they were all closer
to the flood area.
Like they were really young,
like little girls at like camp. I don't >> What the >> Why
is this clip so compressed? It's probably cuz it's from his like
corner camera on his webcam or something. >> Some kids
are they grow up to be they don't just become them, okay? They
they were made that way at a very early stage of life. This idea
that you're supposed to magically care more because of some you
this.
It's so stupid. Yeah, I agree. We should uh we should get rid
of like the juvenile detention system. Just put all people who
are bad, whatever they do, into prison. There's no hope of reforming
those kids. Okay, those kids are which is actually closer to
the truth in some ways. Okay, people who are young and committing
like insane crimes probably in trouble. But you get a chance.
Okay. You get a chance to turn your life around and people do.
>> You can charge kids as adults in certain conditions.
That has happened depending on their age. Yeah, it does happen.
>> Like when the news mentions that women and children
bombing, why do you think they do that, Grand? Hold on. Can you
tell me why? Why do you think they do
>> I'm just I'm waiting for this guy to answer. Yeah, that's
exactly what it is, Kuroko. They're less set in their ways. Also,
I just don't know. It's to pull at your heart. Yeah, sorry. Yes,
exactly. I thought you were making a different argument. Yes.
It's like everybody cares. It's just a denial of shared humanity.
That's like a thing. Um, you are one of the most cringe losers
on the planet Earth. If you think a denial of shared humanity
makes you cool, every single edge lord does it. They go, "Oh,
I'm not like the rest of humans. I'm like kind of different from
every The denial of shared humanity is like one of the most cringe-worthy
things you can do. It is just you trying to like It's just you
begging for people to pay attention to you. It's always weird.
Like you should if you are like an outlier. If you're like very
different from most humans, you should actually feel like slightly
embarrassed of that sometimes. Okay. You're like, "Yeah, I don't
feel Listen, people just care about kids. People just there's
no reason to care about kids." Yeah. You're just cringe. like
nobody. >> This exact This exact mentality is why they
had to make rules about letting children and women off of ships
first or it was just mostly men that survived.
>> We have these things in place because you already don't
care. So, we got to put these things in place to make you >> Oh,
maybe apostate. Actually, hold on. Feel embarrassed. Maybe not.
You should feel like some level of inquiry. You should feel self-conscious.
Okay? And you should figure out why you feel that way and like
what it means about you because technically what he's doing right
now is like just advertising. I'm I'm a terrible person. I'm
a sociopath. I don't have like human emotion. It's goofy as [__]
right?
>> Or maybe it's not Goofy. I think uh I think we've seen
like quite a bit of evidence that >> he's basically just
signaling out to other people who feel that.
If Destiny was on the Titanic, he would be like, "Don't you know
this is a girl's name?" People were jumping on the >> Maybe
the worst joke that's ever been told in the stream, Kelly, and
I'm here like eight hours a day. So,
Uh, I've definitely said this in chat before, too. What makes
Destiny's jokes about this uncomfortable is that I'm sure I'm
not sure he's joking. Wait, he's not joking. This isn't a joke.
This isn't a joke. I'm not going to analyze it further. He's
lucky that I don't hate him enough to analyze it further, but
some people will. like if there was somebody that this could
be applied to who also is starting to gain a presence on the
internet and I would wonder how that this these comments would
affect
>> But he's got no concern for anybody else in his life
whatsoever. He just does this. It's kind of gross, but whatever.
>> He's relying on people not bringing that up, I'd imagine,
because he knows that they will think it's unhinged and he can
just say it's unhinged. >> Most uh Yeah, true.
>> I I don't even have like a It's not like it's morally
wrong to say that. It's just like inhuman and weird. You just
like a weird gross loser that it's really embarrassing that I
thought you were like a good person at some point. I feel like
actual embarrassment watching that. I was like I used to watch
this I used to watch this guy and think he wasn't just one of
the biggest losers on planet Earth. It's like actually embarrassing
for me to watch that.
No, you're exactly right, K though. Yeah, we don't.
Anyway,
thanks for the clip, Ozel. Appreciate it, buddy. Okay, where
are we going next? What do we got? What do we got? We looked
at this tweet. Oh, there's an aristocracy tweet.
Aristocracy did not like the denims tweet, guys. She did not
like it. I find this incredibly weird. Putting a quote about
the need to annihilate with and is one thing, but profiting from
it when you're being accused of anti-semitism is another. I can't
imagine anyone on the left doing this to any other minority.
Uh, okay. This is incredibly incredibly dude. I you don't get
to make this point without criticizing Ethan. Okay? You have
to criticize Ethan's use of these these these pictures and the
comparisons in that document. If you just criticize Denims here,
you are such a loser. You are so performative. You are so
like so in your feelings. You have to you have
criticize both. >> Also, she's not wearing a SS uniform.
She's holding a picture of the court dock. I don't [__]
>> I wish that I wish that somebody hadn't performatively
used these pictures in comparisons, okay, to force Denims to
need to fund raise. That would have been so cool. We would have
all appreciated that. Hey, maybe somebody could not force Denims
to fund raise here. Oh, Grandy, thank you for the sub in new
individual sub. Brand new. Let's go. Thank you very much. But
yeah, like she was literally forced to fund raise for this. She's
got to do it somehow. I accuse you of anti-semitism. I use the
accusations of anti-semitism to put comparisons of like and the
the mufty in here. Okay. And then because I accuse you of antise-mitism,
you can't talk about my lawsuit. You can't use a picture from
that lawsuit to fund raise.
>> Okay. Uh >> chat, can you just be normal? Like
these these chat comments are not passing the vibe check. Jesus.
>> Wait, which one? >> The one that says this gives
tea girl image and other people saying she's like manfaced or
looks like a trans person. Like that's not passing the vibe check.
That's bad. She looks fine. You guys >> I just disavow
those comments entirely.
>> Yes,
obviously. >> I probably say they're a little sick to me.
Like I don't know why you would look at this and go vibes. >> I
I immediately added to this thing, but okay. It's the way >> the
way she's posed. What? She's just
>> What does that have to do with any of the things you
guys just said? You chud viewers, where did you come from? >> Do
you think Wait, wait, wait. Also,
do you think most people even know
>> by the way, I'll just point out that the obvious thing
here. Okay, what what was that? Hold on. See that? Is it a Twitch
>> Matt NLT, thank you for the tier 2 resubed three months.
Let's go. Thank you very much, Matt NLT. All right. The funny
thing about this is that probably you look at the picture here,
right? How else would you be able to tell this is the Ethan Klein
lawsuit if you didn't have these pictures? These pictures are
like the most iconic part of it, right? That's what makes it
obvious that it's the Ethan Klein lawsuit. You'd have to zoom
out or sorry, you'd have to zoom in to know what it is otherwise,
right? She's just fundraising and yeah, it's like a million views,
5,000 bookmarks. Okay. I don't think this picture is what makes
people view this image and bookmark it. I just don't think so.
Do you see the error about this? Yeah, that's what we came from
was the suite about this. Dummy.
Dummy. You You dummy. Like you you sue her and then you go it's
actually anti-semitic to reference the lawsuit in your only fans
now. What? She got to earn her money back, bro. Anyway, I I just
I think it's incredibly weird to to virtue signal over this to
be honest with you. >> I get it that she's she is narrowing
it down to saying, well, it's weird when you're accused of anti-semitism,
but it's like, okay, but is it a real is it a valid accusation
of anti-semitism? That would be the the problem here. Like her
opinion is she's not anti-semitic. She doesn't hate people and
she's doing this because it's absurd to accuse her of antise-semitism,
right? Are you at all surprised based on who this is? No. But
it's Soy, but using a picture of is weird, even if it's in the
lawsuit. Yeah. But I think it's it's funny to make fun of it.
>> It's funny to mock it
>> and I don't think you should really be criticizing Denims
if you're not willing to criticize uh Ethan Klein for trying
to use this in a totally like it's not even he's not even saying
Denims is like this. He's comparing Hassan to the Grand Lufty,
okay? And including these pictures. Like, go after Ethan for
being so performative and fake about this. Okay, you don't have
to go after Denims. Is it crazy to Is it a crazy take to suggest
that uh this is the least attractive picture of Denims? I think
it's her lip purse. Looks like she has a jaw of chew.
Oh, maybe.
Yeah. I don't know. I don't I'm not really evaluating from that
angle to be honest with you. Not trying to evaluate if this is
I actually don't really have that much to compare it to, to tell
you the truth. Will you react to bad empanadas content nuke on
Ethan that just released? Probably not. Bad empanadas docks people
that I know. So, I feel like probably what I'm going to do is
if I were gonna evaluate that, I'd evaluate it, you know, off
stream, skim it, check it out, make sure I was like good with
the content of it before like platforming the content of it before
platforming it on stream. It's probably a bare minimum for doing
uh bad empanada content. I'm fine with like watching his videos
or watching his clips. I just would want to know what's there
or want to know like the the core of it before I actually pull
it up on stream. I I wouldn't just want to do that in the middle
of a stream. That would be crazy. He kind of crazy. Given what
this guy's accused of. Okay, where are we going from here? Get
the denim thing. We got it locked and loaded. Good, good, good,
good, good.
Okay, I might, you know, we're we're easing into content before
I start in the game of for hope stuff. I might watch this card
card posting video. Okay, card posting our favorite Australian.
Is he Australian?
Okay, Columbbo. Internet Columbbo. We've got this guy. Okay,
apparently Pirate Software tried to get his video taken down.
Jason Thoral tried to take down my video. Lolo, even he is Australian.
Well, we do. Yeah, we do love Card here. >> hello there.
>> Check this out. Quick 5minute video. All right, we'll
see what's going on. >> My name's Card and here on my YouTube
page. I like to make a simple little videos about things that
interest me. This video will just be something of a quick update
for people who might have seen another recent video of mine,
one called You Should Hate Pirate Software, which incidentally
I'll link at the top of this video's description if you want
to go watch it for yourself. Now, I believe and am asserting
that this is the second video. I realize it's the second video.
You know how I know it's the second video? cuz the title of this
video says Jason Thor Hall tried to take down my video lau even
which implies the existence of a previous video that Pirate Software
would have attempted to have taken down. I did a little deductive
reasoning there and I figured you know what there may be a video
before this. But because I understand the criticisms of Pirate
Software and I don't really need to watch them multiple times
from the same from different creators, I probably can just skip
that one and go to the one where hey this guy's saying that his
Pirate Software criticism video got taken down. I think.
>> Jason Thorhaul of Pirate Software
not only inexplicably ended up seeing my little video, but he
got really mad about it and has tried his best to take it down
and to otherwise put it to the best of his ability.
If that interests you, if you want all the juicy details,
just bear with me for a moment and I'll get into why I think
all that. But first, just a little bit of specific context.
A couple of days ago now, I made a video talking about how I
think Jason Thorhaw has been acting really about the Stop Games
consumer rights initiative and why I don't like him and why I
think others shouldn't like him
>> Now, my YouTube page is by content creator standards
really, really small.
I don't get a lot of views. >> Uh, that's not true. 6.6K
views, 9.22K
subscribers. Card's card is doing well.
>> If something I make get a thousand views total, I think
that's super. That is beyond all my wildest expectations.
>> That's not true. He's been doing bigger videos for a
while. He's being performatively humble right now. Okay, bro.
You're being performatively Oh. 2.8K, 6.6K,
1.41. It's like all of his card counting 1 to 10,000. Is is it
that the videos where he counts exact numbers 1 to 10,000 10,000
to these videos don't have views? Really? Really?
Uh-huh. Dog whistles 101.
Like his videos get views. His videos do get views all the time.
Okay. >> This video I did recently, you should hate Pirate
Software.
I guess the mysterious YouTube algorithm liked it or it's just
a really popular topic right now because my recent video got
about 9,000 views in 2 days and it's still gradually ticking
up bit by bit. That's huge by my standards.
It's not technically my most popular video outright, but it comes
very close and it's certainly the only video of mine that's done
that well in such a short period of time. >> Cool. And
I will also assert that remarkably
Hall happened to see my video when it only had about 400 views
on it and he watched it privately and got exceedingly angry at
what he considered to be an attack on his character.
Even if it's just coming from absolute small fry like me. And
I also believe, although the exact details here may be a little
bit speculative on my part, Hall has tried to officially report
my video to YouTube as being some sort of terms of service rulebreaking
targeted harassment. What?
Unacceptable.
Uh, Pirates Offer of course loves doing this. He, not unlike
Ethan Klein, loves using the DMCA system or any reporting mechanism
he can to silence criticism. Even if that criticism is hinged,
even if that criticism is of like tiny clips just pointing out
like unhinged things from before, okay, he will use whatever
tool he can to silence criticism. Pirates offer is a piece of
[__] About 24 hours after he tried this, it became
clear to him that this would not be successful.
YouTube evidently declined to agree with him there if they actually
took his complaint in at all. So instead, around this time, Hall
instructed people within the innermost circle of his fan community
on services like Discord and elsewhere to mass report my affforementioned
video themselves and report my YouTube page and seemingly to
leave a bunch of comments under that video calling me wrong and
a bully.
which is by the way also the reason that if you go to my you
should hate Pirate Software video and filter the comments by
chronological order basically the only comments expressing significant
disagreement with me all happen to have been left within one
like 30 minute period roughly 25 hours after and also come to
think of it telling your fans to wrongly mass report a video
you don't like does seem like a sort of targeted harassment doesn't
it but I'd agree >> it does >> also I'm >> it
does it's kind of weird Weird that YouTube allows like offplatform
harassment, isn't it? Like, hey, if a YouTube creator isn't doing
this all from like one channel and one video they post, we actually
aren't going to do anything. That's sort of weird. I feel like
that's kind of weird.
>> And that video, >> what was the video that this
guy did that he asked to get reported? I don't >> criticism
of Pirate Software. Yeah. >> Yeah. But if there's nothing
that you can DMCA, you can't DMCA. So, what what were they reporting
it under?
>> I don't know.
Yeah, that I have not watched this for longer than you have,
Kelly. He has not provided that information. >> Did you
not? No, that's not what I'm asking. I'm like, did you watch
this >> Did I watch the previous video? I did >> Okay,
so we don't have any context.
>> No, I I literally explained why I didn't watch the previous
video earlier in this earlier in the stream. I literally explained
it to somebody. >> Oh, okay. I missed that. I Sorry, I
just went to the bathroom. What was that?
>> Oh, it was that um I've watched like a lot of private
software criticism. I don't really need to see more. So, I was
just interested that Pirates Offer took his video down. We can
watch it after this, though. >> We can go back and watch
>> his video back up.
>> Yeah. Well, it didn't get taken down, so that's why
it's trying to take the video
>> Well, I mean, at the end of the day, if someone says,
"Go report this and it does nothing," then nothing's happened.
>> I don't know. >> Yeah. Uh the the wait if if if
somebody calls for like the death of someone and nothing happens,
is that an okay thing to do?
>> Depends if there was intent. I feel like there was more
intent there. Yes,
I've said
I've made very obviously joking death threats to people before.
But in the case of like if you were going to reference Destiny
specifically,
feel like there's enough to justify intent,
>> Sure. Sure. All right, sounds good. >> How about
that? Now, at this point, you should be thinking, "Card, this
all sounds perfectly plausible based on what we know about Jason."
>> Wow, at least the YouTube reporting system is less than
Discords. Hey, >> so true. >> But ideally, you'd
show us proof. That's very true and very astute of you to say.
And I do have proof. I have receipts, as the Tik Tok team say.
And I'm going to hold on to them for at least a little bit. I
have receipts as the Tik Tok teens say. Love this guy. >> The
way I see it, I imagine that this video will make its way sooner
or later back to Hall himself too. Which means there is an outside
chance, a small chance, but a chance he publicly addresses it
even if in just in some small capacity like on Twitter or whatever.
And firstly, I just want to know what parts of my narrative here
he denies. if any. Will he admit he tried to have my video taken
down by YouTube mods? Will he admit to the fact he got his fans
to try and do the same? Or will he admit to he got them to be
annoying little toadies in my comment section for a while? I'm
hoping that we might be able to get some specific denials from
him on record before I tip my hand fully here. Apologies to anyone
who might have liked to see some repeats. Now, >> I do
like this though. I do like this idea of like it's really gay
when somebody won't really comment on something, but they clearly
want something to happen. He's basically saying like, "Yeah,
I'm claiming he did these things. I want to see if you'll deny
it before I post proof." That's what I want. Go ahead, deny it.
Deny if it didn't happen.
I hate when people say like when they won't say this part out
loud, right? They don't post any receipts, but they also don't
say what they're doing at all. I don't know. I like it. I like
it that he's upfront about it. Okay. >> Why you awesome?
But
I have considered my options here and I do believe this will
be the right way to do this.
Trust the plan because I don't think Jason
necessarily realizes
the extent of what I happen to know here. And at this point since
I think he's watching,
I'll just look directly to camera for a moment to say, "Hey,
Jason,
all your friends hate you, sucker." Anyway, >> oh I this
is a inevitable thing when you start covering Pirate Software.
By the way, lots of people hate this guy. Lots of people reach
out to creators and are like, "Hey, did you know XYZ? Do you
know like all of these different things? You know about all these
different dramas? Hey, did you know this guy's a total piece
of like in an multitude of ways?" Yeah, this happens a lot. Okay,
there are a lot of people who reach out and are like, "Dude,
this guy sucks. You have no idea how badly he sucks." and then
like link you a whole bunch of >> if worst comes to pass
if we hear nothing back from him at all. I'll just make another
video in the nearish future dropping everything pertinent. Okay.
As for right now, >> I missed a bit there. >> Thank
you for listening. >> What does he He said that he has
something that he would but he won't tell us about that he wants
to share to
He said, "I want Jason to make a statement about this to deny
that like, you know, uh, that he mass reported my video, that
he reported in the first place. I want him to deny those things
and then I can post receipts of those. And also, I want you to
keep in mind that all of your friends hate you and I know significantly
more about you than you would imagine. So, be careful in >> Okay,
that's weird.
>> Why would this guy know all of his friends either?
Uh the implication there being that when I made my first video,
people hate you enough that they reached out to be like, "Hey,
this guy actually sucks way more than you realize, >> which
is a very common phenomenon, a very common phenomenon with Pirate
Software." Probably. I would imagine. He's a very offputting
fellow. >> I doubt it. Like your actual people that are
good friends of yours are going to reach out to random people
on YouTube like yap about you. That doesn't seem very likely.
>> Probably not. I don't know why he said it that way,
but who knows? >> Maybe like friends are friends. I could
believe that, right? Or something like this. Actual friends,
>> maybe. Um, let's go grab going to shamelessly take a
little bit of cards first video. It's only 4 minutes 42
>> so I'm going to play this. I'm going to go to the bathroom,
get a little water, and I will be right back. Kelly, I can pause
if you need me to.
>> Okie dokie. >> All right, I'll be right back.
>> Hello there. >> Surrounded by so many old computers.
>> I don't know. It's an aesthetic, >> but I'll be
right back. What is the aesthetic like being stuck in the '9s?
>> YouTube page. I like to make simple little videos about
things that cross my mind. Today, I just want to briefly articulate
some thoughts on a topic I've tangentially
brushed up against before, but it's something that might need
to be restated unabashedly at this point. You should hate pirate
software.
Realistically, if you're ever watching this, you already know
who that is. internet commentator, live streamer, and ostensibly
games developer Jason Thor Hall. And today, I just wanted to
express for the sake of anyone who might still need to hear it.
You shouldn't just merely dislike the man or simply disagree
with his opinions. You should hate him and everything he stands
for and represents. I don't necessarily
>> want this video to be just a laundry list of everything
bad he's ever done. go to YouTubers to decide how to hate, >> who
to hate and who to like. >> That would only be half the
point >> I need someone to tell me that. >> Sure,
you could mention Pirate Softwar's years and years of based off
his neo hire do nothing former job or how he treats literally
everyone he publicly
>> Kelly, why are you being so like autistic about that?
He's not saying you like He's just saying it's like a turn of
phrase. It's like a way of speaking. He is speaking like uh emphatically.
It's not He's not literally saying you have to hate this guy.
>> He's not saying, "Hey, just in case you needed a YouTube
purpose, doesn't it?" There's no other purpose.
How literal he means it is irrelevant when it only
art. He's trying to describe how like awful this person is. >> I
mean, it's also very biased. Like, >> obviously, I've only
met him a few times. What I will say is
>> like a bunch of >> Yeah. a bunch of people I know
like him. Like Annie Fuchsia was with hanging out with him most
of the time and like
it was like Connor and a few other like bigger YouTubers invited
him to that party that we went to on the Sunday and like he knew
most of the people in there and my friends liked him because
they all like animal and like they were just yapping about animal
fundraising stuff. >> They know that everyone hates him.
>> Nobody a ferret. Shut up. That's not possible. You it
>> Yeah. Well, why do you think he has so many injured
and sick parrots there? >> Shut up. That's gross and weird.
>> That's so gross. It's not even funny. It's just yuck.
>> Okay. All right. Maybe he was bosshing it. Okay. He
just kind of like gets I'm not going to continue. I won't continue.
I won't continue.
absolute condescension and any blemurs in the chat. >> Or
you could mention how most recently he's inserted himself into
a consumer rights campaign to just be a fict columnist wrecker,
lie a whole bunch about the movement itself and refuse to apologize
for what he's done. You could mention all that, but I won't because
you shouldn't have to keep track of every sing. >> But
like in a literal sense, you actually did just mention all those
things.
Why did you say that when you also mentioned the right Kelly?
He mentioned those things, but then he said, "I won't mention
them." Isn't that >> Yeah. I don't know. I don't know why
this guy didn't just post the receipts in the last video. Why
does he need for Pirate Software to give them attention before
he posts the receipts?
>> This is like very cringe. >> This is This is the
first video, by the way, the one that he tried to get taken >> No,
I know. I know. I'm referencing like the strange behavior in
this video to the one from before. Like, I don't
>> I don't get it.
>> It's like get on with it and just speak
Yeah, for real, dude. For real. >> This is done. It doesn't
need to be your job or my job to maintain a complete record of
every single slimy thing someone or else has done. All you need
to keep in mind, I don't like that. Hold on. I don't like that.
There should be some way of doing it. Now, he could say, "I've
done the research. I'm putting my reputation on this. I trust
it." Or whatever. But realistically, somebody should have the
research done to know that this is like that he's actually bad.
I don't like I really hate that idea of like you don't need anybody
to prove this to you. No, you should feel like if you have opinions,
you can stand behind them and at some point you should have run
them down to like their base. At some point, you should have
like uh figured out why you think what you think. You don't have
to always remember everything you thought, but you should be
able to run it down. And if somebody challenges on you you on
it, you should be able to know where to go to run it down again.
If you can't do that, then you don't really have business like
giving your opinion on on you know what I mean? is that he's
worth hating.
You know it, I know it. It's not discreet actions here and there
or being assigned badness points and getting weighed up at the
end of the day to see if someone's a good person or not.
>> It's not what he has done and keeps doing. It's just
his personality, his motivations, what pirate software is at
the core of his being. >> This greedy, lying, antisocial
little wretch. People like this are always worth hating. The
narcissists, the bloiators,
the people who try to lord industry connections from being on
the computer all day over you as if that makes them better people.
These people who choose to argue against the public interest
because of their own short. >> Kelly, you want to tell
me about how you hang out with Pirates Offer and Annie Fuchsia
again? >> I don't know what you're is a sarcas. >> It's
a joke. It's a joke. Don't worry about it. Don't worry about
it, Kelly. >> What is the joke? >> This scum. >> He
was just He made a He was saying, "Oh, this guy lords his connections
to other streamers as if it makes him better than other people."
And I joked, "You don't actually do that." It was a joke. Don't
worry about it. We go. We >> And you're allowed to think
it's good when they finally get some semblance of push back or
comeuppance for their actions. There's some people out there
in the world who think it's just inherently wrong or regressive
or childish to hate people or to rail against public figures
online or whatever. And those people are wrong. Wrong and just
trying to run cover for all the other people in the world who
deserve criticism. When do you find someone who like pirate software
deserves all the hate they're getting and much much more?
Encourage that hate. feed it. Remind yourself and others. >> Wait,
who turned the Discord back on? Why did somebody turn the Discord
back on? How long has it been on for? That's against the rules,
bro. >> That it's perfectly okay.
>> It's been ages, hasn't it?
>> Scoobs, thank you for the new one month. Thank you very
much. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. No, it's uh it was supposed
to be for the first hour and I think we got down to what, like
Yeah, we just two minutes over. So maybe somebody's watching.
You said 1 hour. I said 1 hour on the timer or whatever. But
if you only turn it on 2 minutes ago is easy. That's fine. Boom.
We good. >> Wish all the worst in the world on this guy
and people like him. Pirate software hates you. >> Yeah.
No, it's exactly what it was. everyone he sees as below him,
which includes people who watch him, people who don't watch him,
all the other creators online who he's lied about or lied to
or tried to attack through legal means maliciously and wrongly.
And I guess he even hates all the people closest to him to who
he once called friends given our >> so insane. This guy
is so cringe. Would you really rather hang out with this guy
>> and pirates offer? Yeah, every day of the week. Really?
This guy?
>> You believe the stuff that he's saying?
>> I believe what?
>> Wait, what do you what do you think is going on here?
>> I've watched this guy interact with the people he interacts
with like fairly regularly and no, he's a complete piece of [__]
>> Um, he might be nice to big people, big streamers with
a bunch of connections, but in general, no. He's like uh and
in in person he might also be nice, but the way he acts on the
internet is like incredibly cringe. Yeah, >> the majority
of the people he was hanging out with that I spoke to as well,
one of them is British because he's his mod and he was very nice
to him. One of them was also a very small coding creator who
ran his D&D campaign and I spoke to her a lot because her
son has
uh idiopathic thrombocytoenia
pure
um and oh there was like a couple of other people there.
Well, not only why, but it's like I spoke to her about that a
lot.
>> Um,
like they were just So, it was a pretty big range of people.
It wasn't just creators. It was like literally one of his own
community members that was a mod and smaller creators, too.
>> There's a lot of evidence for just like how he treats
people on the internet,
>> Well, yeah. I wouldn't I wouldn't trust like the one
event that's a totally like just purely a Twitch marketing or
sorry Twitch like networking event. I wouldn't trust that one
event for like how he behaves versus just looking at how looking
at all the
>> Well, I can judge the things that other people wouldn't
see, right? Like their DND campaign wasn't done on a stage. It
was done in like the a corner of the hotel with nobody watching.
Okay. So I think there's like enough interactions that I saw
that I could just >> watch him have one D and D campaign
where he wasn't like a total malignant
>> Well, no. I was like obviously there for the whole event
like my friend who um he ran the first party on the first night.
Um he invited him. So like there were a number of interactions
where there was like enough for me to like make a at least semideent
observation. Somebody just asked like a pretty good question.
Was Destiny nice to you uh in person? Has Destiny been nice to
you in person? >> Not always. He was. So like uh the first
we don't you don't even have to actually go through it. I'm just
saying that like even if he was the whole time, I don't think
we'd let that undo a bunch of the other things we know about
him, right? >> Yeah. But he's there's a lot of evidence
of other things. >> It's not really comparable to being
annoying online, is it? >> It's not really annoying. It's
like a narcissist with no capability whatsoever of analyzing.
>> Okay. It's not comparable. Yes. Destiny is much worse.
Yes. >> Uh it's comparable in that the evidence for both
is overwhelming. >> Is Destiny much worse? Yes.
>> Yes. But I already gave you
it's not in their crimes. >> It's not in their I'm not
comparing their crimes. I'm not comparing like what they've done
wrong at all. >> Of course I'm not. Why would I do that?
Why would I minimize what Destiny's done? I'm saying that the
evidence is overwhelming for the negative conclusions about both
of them.
>> Um, I mean, I have not watched his content, so I can't
really criticize that. And I didn't see a huge amount of like
the stuff coverage you did like um, was it like a month ago,
two months ago? I can't remember when it started.
>> Mhm. Uh, like six months ago now.
>> This is 6 months ago. Jesus Christ. Yeah. So, like someone
being a dumbass in World of Warcraft is not like something I
would care about, I guess. >> Do you think that's an accurate
description of what he did in World of >> It's a video
game. Anything anyone does in a video game? >> Do you think
he was criticized for his actions in the video game World of
Warcraft? Do you think that was the primary criticism of him?
>> His actions. >> That was the first thing, wasn't
it?
>> That was the first thing. Okay. >> Well, he did
get a lot of criticism for that. I'm not saying that's the only
thing he's criticized for. Now, >> his guildmates actually
all stood up for >> Okay. Then I I thought that was the
first thing that he got a lot of >> It was the first thing,
but it was what it was what led to it. So, his guild mates were
like, "No, no, no. This isn't a big deal." And then people stopped
or sorry, he started looking into his other stuff, his other
interactions. He had really bad interactions with other people
in the guild. And he refused to actually just apologize and be
like humble at all. In terms of his first clip, it is his total
unwillingness to ever admit fault on anything for any reason
that has him over and over and over again. Even when he is objectively
in the wrong, he will never admit fault. He'll never apologize.
He'll never just go like, "Oh, that's my bad. Oh, he's kind of
an [__] I was a little stressed out. Won't do it."
He'll just go, "No, no, no. I was correct and here's why I was
correct." And then people started looking through his other content
and they go, "Oh, he actually does this everywhere. He actually
refuses to admit fault and and actually gaslight other people
into believing that they're the problem everywhere. He does this
constantly as like a just consistent part of his personality.
That is what the criticism was. >> Let's just I'll just
say what you've said is just objectively true. He has a bad personality
flaw. Who doesn't?
>> Is that enough to like condemn someone as being evil
and like >> go on this type of tirade? I mean, I don't
like apologizing that much sometimes, right? I guess why do you
talk to me then? >> should I just be thrown out in the
trash? Do my positive qualities not counteract your negative
ones? >> You are to most people who aren't close friends
with you like dangerously close to this level of yes doing this
where you will refuse to admit fault, refuse to apologize and
a lot of people do dislike you for that. I have personal interactions
that overlap with that and so I can see past it but I'm telling
you that a lot of other people do see it that way. >> Okay.
A lot of other people are just this community which is moderately
meaningless. Okay. Like I've never lost a single friend in real
life for this being an issue. I like debating so what's the point
of apologizing in a debate sphere? It's not really the same context.
I I don't know. Otherwise, you would weigh negative qualities
which reminder everybody has against their positive qualities,
right? And my positive qualities obviously outweigh the negative
ones or you wouldn't talk to me. >> Sure. But like if you
were a content creator and you were doing this all the time,
then people in that content creation sphere could hate you for
it. >> I think this would know you personally. They wouldn't
know you personally to >> Well, I think this level of hate
for a negative personality trait is insane. This level of hate
for someone who's a
is valid. I I don't know. I think you'd have to do something
worse for me to feel like it's valid. >> Yeah. He also
puffs up his own achievements like significantly. Something you
don't do. like he he basically makes it seem like he is like
an expert in everything. You will say exactly what you know about
something. It is not the same. People will try to say it like
similar to the chemistry thing. It's not. Kelly objectively just
repeatedly says, "Nope, this is high school chemistry. Nope,
this is high school chemistry. I'm not an expert. I don't have
a degree. I don't need a degree. It's high school chemistry."
Right? So, so Pirate Software lies about his achievements for
one thing. Lies about what he's done and how significantly he's
contributed to anything that he's involved in. And he talks down
to a lot of other people who know more than him all the time.
>> Uh yeah, I don't know what those things are, I guess.
Do you want to talk about those things? Like >> the stop
games thing. You're not really >> We could go Wait, we
actually could go through the whole stop games thing as well.
Do we want to go through the stop? This is actually like the
perfect segway into stop games. I have all the stuff ready to
go do it. Um I might be missing some stuff right at the end,
but I have all the stop game stuff. We can go through that and
you'll get to see like very very clearly how he will misrepresent
a movement. He'll refuse to engage back with these people. He
will try to get this movement killed basically like he will his
opinion will significantly harm this movement and he will refuse
to ever take accountability for how he was wrong for months and
months and months and months until it spirals and it destroys
him. >> Mhm. Okay. >> Okay. So, we could do it. We
could do it. We could do it. Icy Bob, I saw you. I was watching
some Kino Kino casino clips. I saw you in the chat. I saw you
in the chat there. I didn't realize you watched like a lot of
other people, but I I saw you I saw you chilling with the Kino
Casino guys. Those guys >> feeling bad to be a stubborn
person. I like stubborn people.
Or is it is it like everyone in the internet just hates anyone
who's stubborn? It's very sad. I'm I'm talking to the chatters.
I'm not saying that's all you think pirate software is. I'm just
saying as long as the person has some good stuff going, let them
be stubborn. I think you're able to walk Kelly through things
and she will accept some things too in a way that pirates offer
never ever ever ever ever
done. Debate Queen on SKG. I I haven't watched all of the SKG
stuff to have like a ton of opinion there to be honest with you.
So I have to I have to go watch it. I I skipped that whole thing.
The Minecraft dude came out against Thor the other day, right?
Notch. Well, I mean Notch just said, "Why is a Nepo baby whining
about games or something like that?" He I forget the quote. with
the positive things about Kelly. I mean, I'm not going to get
into it, but obviously she's a she's somebody who can be like
a good friend. I've said this before multiple times on stream.
You need to see that. You can go back and watch it. >> Pretty
sure I've been here every I've been here since the start.
I've been here since like the initial issues in January. And
I was here after the last too. So, you make from that what you
>> before all of it. Before all of it, too. >> Before.
Sorry. What do you mean? >> Before like you were here.
You were just here on the stream so long ago >> all the
time.
>> Why are these getting posted in my chat? What? Why were
people drawing Chud
>> They're getting posted in my Discord right now. What
is happening? Are people good? Are people okay? Are humans doing
human things or are artists are really starting to crack under
the pressure of AI, guys?
They're not doing their best work right now. Right. They're really
starting to crack under the pressure. It is becoming painful.
It's not good. Not good at all. All right, we have to finish
the pirate software video from card. We're pull it back 20 seconds.
We're going to continue. >> Who is lied about or lied to
or tried to attack through legal means maliciously and wrongly
and I guess he even hates all the people closest to him too who
he once called friends given our pirate software simply >> Kelly's
redeeming qualities. Exactly. Did you really you follow just
ask that question? There are lots of them. I'm not gonna go about.
>> Was he not following beforehand?
>> That guy followed literally two seconds ago. Just asked
that question. Brand new account. Probably somebody who's banned
before. We'll see. >> Being during his buddies game night
is what started getting people to take a closer look at what
else he gets up to. Anyway, and if Pirate Software hates everyone,
it's only right everyone hates him back. Please do so. Please
feel free to sincerely,
passionately, unreservedly
hate Jason
and people like him.
>> Just keep it in mind. >> Anyway, goodbye for now.
>> Okay. Have a lovely day. Where what was he reporting
this for? What would you report this for to YouTube? And what
would you tell people to mass report him >> Being cringe.
>> Ah, that's what I thought. Do you think it's gay to
mass report things when you just when you're just mad? when you're
just raging out. Kelly,
>> yes, but on YouTube it does nothing and it did nothing.
>> I don't I don't care. That's not what I >> There
is no cringe button. I wish there
>> But they didn't report him for cringe. They would have
had to lie. They would have had to lie about what he was doing.
>> I know. It was a joke. >> Yeah. Well, I think
lying to try to get somebody deplatformed, trying to get their
videos taken down just because they're criticizing you is gross.
I think that's wrong. It's wrong to do,
you know.
You know, you know,
>> Okay. Boom. There it is.
Josh where he cast doubt on his brony defense. No, I have not
seen that. >> I swear to God if this is like a 10 sub YouTuber
who's crying about not having his video taken done, then this
guy sucks. I don't who is >> 10,000 subs, 12,000 views,
20,000 views on the other video. >> Oh god, who cares?
>> I care. I think you could just look at situations and
be like, "Yeah, this guy's kind of a this pirates offer guy is
kind of a piece of >> wonder how many of these subs he
gained from just making this type of content." >> Uh, most
of his content is exposing right-wing dog whistles. Uh, because
he's a progressive political activist, an organizer of 10 years
or something like that. Dog dog whistles 101. These are like
most of his videos, right? >> About uh like racism, racism,
racist dog whistles and Yeah, that's like most of his content.
Wait, so it's like actually important stuff and then he just
wastes his time on play software. >> Maybe I mean he does
politics stuff and then he does online drama stuff a little bit
too and Yeah. Yeah. >> caring about racism is valid. I
just this stuff is uh it's kind of dumb.
>> Joe Queen is a non. No, I'm good. No, I'm good without
playing the Queen video. I know that Queen video and he listen
Card's finest work. Okay. Queen came out and said, "Hey, this
is my position." He clarified it and Card was like, "You know
what? You're okay. That's the beginning and end of that story.
It's kind of boring to be honest. >> He He made a video
on Queen.
>> If you like the content, okay, go ahead and follow on
every platform. Follow on kick. Follow on Twitch. twitch.tv/jlk
with an underscore. On Twitter,
with an underscore. All right, join the Discord. Discord.gg/jk.
If you'd like to take your support one step further, you can
also throw me a couple bucks. Adds time to the stream. Uh adds,
you know, food to my life so I can live. so I can live and buy
new balls to bounce on. Okay, let's go. Guys, you can donate
a couple different ways, okay? You can donate through kick. You
can donate kick subs. You can sub individually on kick. Two people
have subbed individually today. I love individual subs way more
than gifted subs because individual subs show that you are personally
invested in the stream and you are adding recurring revenue to
my channel. So, it it re resubs every month. I really appreciate
guys individual subs even more than gifted subs. But, I love
gifted subs and on kick it's a 955 split. So, I get to keep most
of the money. We love kick. We love kick. We love kick. Okay.
We love kick. We love kick. All right. >> This guy gets
less views than rile. >> Uh-huh. So, anyway, also you can
donate through the TTS links. You buy a TTS message. Explanation
donate in the chat. We'll give you both of those links. All right.
There is the Kickbot link. $2 minimum on Kickbot AI Voices $3
minimum on Streamlabs.
All right. Donating through all of these methods allows you to
add more time to the stream. You can see the you can see the
the stream goal there. We're at $60 for another hour. So, I appreciate
if you guys would donate. Okay, we love we love donations. I'm
trying to put this Kickbot link in Twitch, but it won't let me
pin it. Cool. All right, there it is. And guys, last
but not least, all right, there's the Patreon. patreon.com/jk.
There's many perks available there. Swim, thank you for the Twitch
Prime. I appreciate it, dude. Appreciate it. Appreciate it. There's
patreon.com/jok.
There's multiple roles, multiple membership paths. $5 tier gets
the ability to talk in Discord for the first hour of the stream.
They get soundboards in the Discord. They get priority access
to call-ins. And then the the benefits only snowball from there.
At the tier, there's access to private postream and pre-stream
calls that we do, you know, on a fairly regular cadence. All
right, fairly regular. And there's the $100 tier which comes
with way more perks and stuff like lots of fancy. But don't buy
that if you have any financial difficulty. Only buy this if you
make over six figures a year American. Make under six figures
a year American. Don't buy this. It's not worth it for you. Okay?
It's not worth it.
>> But yeah, that's the that's the show guys. Thank you
very much for the support. Sim, thank you for the primer. And
we continue on with the stream.
>> thumbnail is just a picture of Queenman with nons question
>> n question mark.
Is this guy kn? >> I want to know.
>> Is this Kai Knots? Hard to say. Difficult to put into
words. All right. Oh, why did I go to this? No. No. No. Yes.
This robot is trained to Will
>> So, like my opinion of this is you probably shouldn't
ever report these types of YouTubers because it just does end
up by like Barbara Stries ending yourself, right? Um, but also
this guy's top three videos of the last month are all pirate
software. So, he was just kind of leeching on the name, right?
>> I don't know if I'd want to talk to this guy either.
He seems like a cringe. >> Black Ice 32, thank you for
the primer. Uh, Kelly is doing this. Obviously, I'm self-aware.
I realize that is basically all of my content. So, I will never
criticize somebody doing that. Holy, I'm very self-aware. I would
never do that. Okay. As if I don't also criticize or other people.
This guy's got incredibly varied content. What? What are you
talking about? He's got all the dog whistle >> How is that
varied? >> Uh, there's political content, there's drama
content. Those are totally different things. Totally different
verticals entirely. >> Well, that's why all of those videos
only get like 200 views.
>> No, lots of stuff where he's doing like drama and putting
other people's names in it gets more views. That's why he does
it. Obviously, >> that's true for everybody. >> You
don't make videos
anymore.
But yeah, that's why I didn't like Riyle too much when he was
doing it and all of the videos were like demented.
>> I didn't enjoy that.
>> Okay. All right. >> Doesn't matter now, but it
was very unenjoyable a few months ago. Well, 6 months ago, whatever
it was. I don't >> Sim says, "Kelly can only be this disruptive
and negative with her cam on." I don't think so. I think she
could do it when in any scenario. Kelly can always be this negative
and disruptive. What are you talking about? Why would you Why
would you pretend she's incapable of that? That's goofy.
>> Sorry. Go ahead.
>> Oh, I wasn't going to say anything.
>> Okay. Even streamers use names and titles to draw people
in. Yeah, exactly. That happens all the time.
>> It's like a consistent thing. All all the time. Okay.
Well, man, uh I'm in a tough spot. I kind of want to watch, but
I don't know how to intro this. Basically, um, Ieko, if you guys
remember, Ieko came on to criticize me a couple days ago, and
then she also talked she's been like kind of going after Straight
Raid for leaking the the Pixie DMs and stuff. It's like a little
weird to me how she has like heat for Straight Raid. And then
she went on and she interviewed Smug Bug today talking about
the leaks of Pixie DMs again cuz Straight apparently might have
shared it with these people. And I just find the whole thing
funny. Okay. I find the whole thing interesting. I didn't criticize
you. Uh, I think there are some criticisms. I think you're wrong,
but it's fine. Uh, criticisms are fine. I don't I'm not going
to ever get mad at somebody for criticizing me. If you if you
have criticisms and you're willing to talk about it, it's fine.
Is Io chill with Sunday? Very chill with Sunday. Yes. So, it
is very interesting. >> It's not interesting. You didn't
Did you listen to Iiko's video? The point is that Straight Ace
just said nothing. Every All of the others have said something.
It's just weird that she's not said anything.
>> Yeah. And >> why would she criticize the others
when they've all said stuff? >> Nothing. Who is she criticizing?
>> What? Sorry. She's criticizing the straight array. >> Who
is criticizing? >> IO
is crit criticizing straight raid,
>> Sure. She's criticizing other people now >> Like
who? >> Like Smug Bug. >> I'm confused >> right
now. That's the whole point of the content I'm likely trying
to introduce. >> Smug Bug. I don't >> Yeah, I think
a lot of us know Smug Bug's another creator. He's in the Loaderbox
Discord. He runs the PNO scum podcast with Whiz Wizard Walker.
Okay, they have like a friendship and this is purportedly according
to not so Aerodite. Not so Erdite released this information that
she thought that Straighter had also leaked those DMs to Smug
Bug. Let's pull up the timestamp
Crabs or whatever. He covers all the weeks on stream to Sunday.
I think Beckett
um of Crabs or whatever. He covers all the weeks on stream. It
sounds like Sunday got them directly from her. I don't know how
Becket got them. Um, I think some people are saying that I think
it might have been through Smug Bug because Aaron's good friends
with Smug Bug. I'm I don't know though. I have no idea how Becket
got uh the DMs and I don't know if Nicholas got it from Becket
or from
>> So, there's this like uh kind of mystery of how Becket
got these DMs. I don't know if Becket's spoken about it publicly.
That would be interesting. But um this is Ieko's like looking
for how this leak happened. Okay. Jesus Christ. there's anything
you can do to keep the smug bug audio from peaking for two hours
of screaming. Well, I was going to watch all two hours. I was
just going to watch the beginning and just see the general layout
of the argument. I was interested in it cuz I watched Ieko. I
watched Ieko last night with some people in a Discord a little
bit. Okay. And it was just interesting watching her go through
this and her thoughts on it. And now I kind of wanted to go and
look at her stream today where she actually talks to Smoke Bug
about it and just see what he had to say. You know, I was interested.
Very,
very interested. You know who could clear this up in like 5 seconds?
The person who's not >> or literally Smug Bug or literally
any of these people could could actually clean it up right away.
Wait, what? Hold on. I think um what would straight rate say
here? >> She would be able to know who she's to unless
she's
so many people she could >> No, no, no, no, no. I don't
believe that's even in question here. I don't think that's even
in question. I don't think Shredder has anything to add. From
what I remember, last night on Iiko stream, she said there was
a like a group chat that this got shared in that Smug Bug and
Whiz were a part of. >> She shedded them in group chats.
How many people were in the group? >> Three other people
with three other people. Two of them being Smug and Whiz. I think
they're very close friends of
>> So, but I I just watched through this and we can we
can watch them talk through it. Yeah. Okay. Wait, what if you
had like the same group the this group of three very close friends?
You think that's wrong to like basically talk to them about your
problems? >> Yeah. putting anything into a group chat is
stupid.
>> Uh I would agree for keeping things private. Yeah. A
lot of the time, but I mean she also just DM'd it to Sunday directly
who she trusted as a friend and that was also stupid. So >> they
they are both stupid decisions. >> Yeah. Wow. But I don't
know where her statement would clear up either of those
>> I mean she could say something, right? Saying nothing
is weird. I don't know what she wants to
>> What do you mean why? >> What information she
say that it's weird? Like she could say anything. I don't know
what she what she because it's weird to say nothing.
>> And if you're gonna say why. Yes, it is. Because if
something >> You have to say why.
>> Okay, I will. If you're central to some huge thing that's
happened and you just choose to ignore it and pretend it doesn't
happen and don't comment on it is bizarre.
>> It's not. You're just saying it's weird. You're just
saying it feels weird. I'm telling you, for me, it would be weird
if there was some unanswered question that was important to prosecuting
this case. If there was something we didn't know, that would
be very helpful to know for everybody. Right now, it's just like,
hey, I know you had this thing happen and I think it's up that
you won't come and take your like public lashing for this. That's
really the argument. I don't think it's a reasonable argument.
>> I'm not like that interested in an apology.
It's didn't happen to me, right? But it's just bizarre not to
like you could express remorse for the thing that happened. You
could talk about how bad it was in whatever way. You could talk
about how dumb you were. You could talk about why you made those
dumb decisions. You could talk about literally anything. To say
nothing is >> But what? Hold on. What do you think the
speculation is here that like what you say? Okay. I want to know
why. >> No, no, no. I'm just
speculate on
those are the reasons. Oh my god. Because her decisions led to
something being public. It was her fault >> by spreading
all of this information to other people. So when you make a problem
public, you should probably speak on it. It's like taking responsibility,
right? >> I think you have the ability to just move on
from things personally.
>> I Well, if you don't take responsibility for something,
you're not moving on. You're just avoiding it. >> And hoping
it goes away. >> Yeah. Well, I think basically nothing.
So for for Aaron, the reason I don't like get mad at her not
make a public statement because I know all the facts there already
and I think she's been like appropriately chastised and all this
does is like drudge it up so people can like on her again and
nobody who actually cares about the facts or cares about like
what happened there is unaware. So you're only informing people
who will only want to use that to >> I don't know but okay
>> okay that's how I look at it think you've had the opportunity
to but you >> what that's why I have asked you repeatedly
what do you not understand here? Well, you just said you were
spoken to in private, but I don't know what she said to you.
>> I just I'll say again, why? What do you not know here?
That is like an outlying question for you, right? Cuz you just
were saying that it's about her taking responsibility. I'm saying
I think that's But you're now saying, "Oh, there's some information
I don't have." What information do you not have? >> Okay.
If you're going to if you're going to do the thing where you
keep calling me, I'm going to ask you to be a bit >> I'm
sorry. I said I think it's I'm not calling you. I think the idea
of trying to take her have her take responsibility, but I can
use a different word. >> I think that's silly. >> Something
is not going to go away if you don't address it. >> That's
not how anything works. No, it doesn't. It will continue to come
back to haunt you forever. >> Yeah. Until people get so
bored and die.
>> Like, yes, it Well, it is right now. I am proving the
point because it is happening. IO's been doing all of this content.
I mentioned it to you the last time she came on and then you
had no idea what was going on. She had president Sunday. >> That's
irrelevant to this conversation by the way. >> She had
royal come on a yappy. What? How is that irrelevant? I just said
that this stuff will continue to >> whether or not I understand
what Io is talking about is irrelevant to this >> No, my
point was things will continue to be brought up. >> Sure.
I think Strader's perfectly comfortable with Iiko doing as many
streams about this as she needs to. I don't think that makes
Straighter bothered at all. >> Well, okay. I didn't say
she had to be >> Sure, but you were saying that it won't
go away and it'll keep haunting her. And I think this level of
haunting she doesn't understand or care about is not >> Okay.
Well, she doesn't care. It seems like maybe she's a person that
just doesn't care much in general.
Maybe that's why >> she doesn't care about Aiko covering
it and talking about it. >> Well, I'm sorry. I said she
doesn't care about Iiko covering and talking about >> Yeah.
Not saying anything. Yes. Gives a level of indifference or whatever.
there's some negative character trait that's being exhibited
by that choice. Like I could make my perceptions of those negative
character traits. >> What is the negative character trait?
>> I'm just I'm asking you to lay out your thoughts and
then I'll discuss them with >> There's like two different
uh two groups of them. So there are the negative traits that
I believe that she has due to her initial decisions of sharing
those things to everyone. I think she's a gossip
in a negative way. I think that she's careless and reckless
and probably stupider than I thought.
I think that my character uh assess
assessment of the fact that she's been silent for the last 6
months. The options are she just does not give a [__]
or she's incredibly self-preser
preserving by not wanting to say anything.
Like those are very negative opinions and judgments. Yes, that
doesn't seem like a good thing. >> Uh, yeah, but I don't
think they're like wellounded at all. >> Well, I haven't
had secret meme talks with her, have I? >> No, but I wouldn't
say that using a biased position.
>> I'm not >> I I can literally do it from public
information. That's why I say who who
works would change their opinion based on something she could
say. We know she leaked them to these people, right? What what
information are you missing to make the same criticism as straight
raid? >> There are a lot of just well not necessarily justifications
but there is a lot of additional information that could be gleaned
from her thought processes that might make her look less bad.
And also showing remorse always makes you look better cuz it
means you're not a sociopath who didn't give a
course that's good. What a stupid thing to say. >> I don't
So I don't think that's founded that she doesn't care. >> Well,
how would we know? if she doesn't say anything. >> Um,
so I think the only way you could have that is if you had some
like principle that makes you think somebody not making a statement
on something means they don't care. I think probably for any
of those people, she just doesn't really No, nobody who I can
think of >> who has that opinion is like really justified
in having that opinion. >> Most people when they care about
something will say something. Yes. Most people don't go quiet
when they care about something. Oh, >> Crab Navy says she
did try to speak out about it and people intentionally shut her
down at the time. Okay. I think when >> uh I don't know
what he's talking about. You'd have to you'd have to explain
that further. Crab Navy. No, >> she doesn't owe me specifically
anything. Just asked me what my negative negative character assessment
of her was and I gave it.
>> I would want to be a friend.
>> would you? She'd blab all of your stuff. You'd be [__]
And then you would offer feel bad about it afterwards. Wait,
did Trader really offer to make a statement to Nicholas? And
Nicholas said, "No, >> I'll not be talking to this person,
and nobody else should either." Oh, that's
>> Yeah, at this point, I just don't think it matters at
all. >> Yeah, it just it literally >> like you. I
have never shared anything this important like this with this
many people this carelessly and recklessly in my life.
That's just like a collection of insane
I guess if you do disgusting, just don't acknowledge it. Disappear
for a couple months and it just doesn't matter anymore. True.
>> No, I think basically she like the silence is admitting
she did disgusting,
>> right? No. >> And her continued silence. No, it
absolutely is. If you wanted absolution from people, if you thought
I did something that like you could understand my actions if
I explained them to you, then she would have spoken. She hasn't
spoken. She's like, "Oh, the negative judgments, those are baked
in. I will never be able to change people's opinions on those
things that I did, so I'm just going to move forward." That is
the opinion. That is exactly what it is.
>> If you thought that everyone felt that
then and being okay with the fact that people have such negative
character assessments, which is obviously not true, or she wouldn't
have been talking to you and so many people in private, but let's
just pretend that that's true. so many people, >> then
you'd probably be too embarrassed to show your face around here
again. >> By the way, I I think I initiated contact with
Aaron most of the time. >> Well, I don't care how you spoke
to her. That's relevant to what I just said, isn't it? >> Okay.
All right.
>> I don't think she necessarily agrees, Magic Dragon.
I think she knows that her like personal rationalizations aren't
going to change anybody's mind. Like the truth isn't going to
change anyone's mind. If she talked about how like oh like I'm
not even I she's not said this to me. Okay. But it's a perfectly
like
I guess theory. If she just thought I was incredibly stressed,
my friend group was imploding. Um I wasn't sure like where I
was going to be and I was just trying to make sure that like
nobody was hurt or trying to like minimize damage in this community,
right? And I didn't think it was like that bad at that point.
If this is all the things she's thinking, okay, none of that
mental state, none of that intent actually changes what people
like uh, you know, Sunday or Kelly or Ieko think, right? It does
doesn't change anything. It's It's not going to change anybody's
mind. People are still going to go, "Well, you shared like incredibly
damaging DMs to Destiny with Destiny's like biggest hater in
the world, the guy who would do anything to destroy him." Of
course, that was going to go badly, right? Of course that was
going to go badly. And by the way, that's why I continue to say
that was maybe the most the dumbest decision I've ever seen in
my life. Hey, President Sunday, here's incredibly harmful information
to Destiny. Please don't share it. >> I think just putting
it as dumb.
>> I think just seeing it as dumb is minimizing it cuz
I don't think she's a dumb person. And dumb people,
she'd have to be very stupid. And I don't think stupidity is
the issue to have done that or like made so many multiple bad
decisions. It's like sharing it in a group chat, talking to Destiny,
sharing it to President Sunday, and then all of the things that
she said within all of these chats, like there were a lot of
negative things about people in there that just didn't need to
be said. Like some of them were pretty
like if someone was talking about me and >> I don't know
if you haven't noticed that Aaron is a [__] That's
like a part of her entire personality content creation
>> Okay. A lot of those things were like not upfront with
people. Okay. >> Like I I refuse to believe that cuz it
wouldn't have upset Pixie as much, would >> I So I have
no idea what she said in there. I would imagine she would have
said very similar things to people's faces. I never I've never
gotten the impression that she's duplicitus. I've gotten the
impression that she is kind of like and will say mean things
to people's faces, but that's >> I know that the comments
about Pixie and the comments about Erodite were not to their
faces. Arrodite had no clue she didn't like her. She said she
helped to get a dog and some other I can't remember. Pixie, I
can't remember what Pixie told me that she said about her. It
was just like
>> like out of nowhere kind of.
>> I don't know. I think it might have been like stuff
talking when she's talking about like
the money stuff was just really weird comments. It might have
been something else. I don't know.
Doubt she was up front. Yeah, I just doubt it. >> I just
doubt it. I am very doubtful.
>> But again, that's the thing, isn't it? When someone
says full, I am going to doubt them. I'm not going to give them
>> Yeah. that I think that's like perfectly baked in, right?
If somebody is not going to make a statement on something, you
have every right if you want to to view that as negatively as
you can.
>> And I think that's a part of the calculus because I
know I'm familiar with this line of thinking. Um I don't think
like I don't think anything could say would change people's minds.
I think she's just going to like move forward as best she can
and make the best of things that she can, right? I understand
it. I just I don't um Yeah. Yeah, I don't hate the person. >> So,
were you never bothered about what she did or did she change
your mind? >> What's that? Sorry. No, I wasn't. I totally
understood. I think um maybe more stuff could come out that would
change my mind again, but based on the information that's come
out, I never thought it was like that that crazy. >> So,
you were totally understanding of everything she did before you
even spoke to her?
>> Then why did you speak to her?
>> Uh because I wanted clarification on a
Then why would you had a conversation that made you feel more
reassured if it was just a quick discussion about a
>> How are you so sure about her character if you haven't
really spoken that much? >> I'm just saying is it was my
read on her character from the beginning and I'm understanding
of people who would share something with like a close friend
and somebody they like respected for a long time. She knew Sunday
before she knew Destiny, right? Like that she >> wasn't
just a close friend. >> Yeah. I'm telling you that I can
understand how your your read on a friend and how much they care
about you versus hate somebody else could be totally skewed by
how close you see that friendship being. And you might not realize
that this person will just you because they don't they want to
destroy that other guy, right? I understand how she would be
blind to that. That makes total sense to me. That works within
my mental model of everything. But other people might not. Other
people might just be like, "Oh, no. That's totally unforgivable.
I'll never forgive that." >> She's like, "That's your right."
>> It's not about being blind. It's that she has so many
other people that were far more normal to speak to in the Why
didn't she just speak to Lykan? Why didn't she speak to like
anyone else but [__] President Sunday? Why is she
putting stuff in a group chat? Why is she talking to Destiny?
>> Yeah, I think um there's definitely like some amount
of
oh, I don't know how to describe it. Like cloud seeeking that
could be going on there. Sure. >> I just think she's a
malicious level gossip. Like just likes to stir and like be involved.
>> Yeah. If I if I believed that about her, if I thought
that that's what she was doing to Pixie, I would not be friends
with her. I would not like want her around me. >> I don't.
But
>> yeah, I just it's just reckless
and just >> definitely reckless. I think I've I've said
like bafflingly
is the words I use, >> yeah, I just I don't think it's
because she's not stupid and I think that that kind of undermines
the negativity. If she was as if she was like Darius and clearly
very stupid, I would be thinking differently.
I don't think she is stupid. >> You're you're using a like
you're using her logical intelligence and then condemning her
for an emotional decision is my my criticism, I guess, >> right?
She's smart. She argue stuff. >> And then I think she was
probably from an emotional place sharing with people she shouldn't
have, right? That's how I view it. An emotional reaction
is an event. It's not a series of events in this way. And she
doesn't seem that emotional in the messages at all. So, I don't
I don't agree with that one.
>> All right. >> Like, where was the emotionality
in saying, "Oh, yeah, Pixie's broke. She has to pay me back an
installments for
>> She'd known in this space for a very long time who's
always had the correct read on Destiny. >> Sorry, can you
repeat that? I missed it. in trusting somebody she's known for
a very long time >> that had the correct read on Destiny
from the beginning and he was like a totally emotionless like
lizard person, right? That was the that was the thing that like
she was like, "Oh, I can look past how much he hates this person
because he had the right read and he's been my friend for like
longer than I've even known Destiny." That's probably I I would
imagine it's the calculus that went in. That's how it works in
my head and that's my personal read. But honestly, just argue
my personal read if you want, but like that thing is how people
would make decisions there. But >> you can be biased to
someone and like them a lot and it can cloud your vision, but
it should only ever and it only really can be to a point. It's
like if I know fundamentally this person is a commentary YouTuber
and they hate Destiny. No, >> a commentary YouTuber. President
Sunday is not a commentary YouTuber. He's not a part of the commentary.
What is he then? Totally incorrect. He's like a political commentator.
He's a to it's like a totally incorrect. >> Okay, whatever
that is. Way to focus on the completely relevant point again.
>> Well, commentary are like infamous for leaking. Hold
on. Sunday infamous for leaking as well, but mostly out of negligence
more than uh malice, I would >> Yeah. And putting up
hold just a second. I'm just putting up the kick link in Twitch
chat, guys. I'm ending on Twitch going over to kick only. Enjoy
the rest of the stream on kick only or Twitter if you watch there,
but kick only basically. See you in a bit. Bye-bye. >> He's
a YouTuber that makes videos. Like, that's all I meant by commentary
YouTuber. He has commentary in his videos. I don't really care.
>> Every YouTuber is a commentary YouTuber.
>> Sorry. What was the meaningful >> The meaningful
distinction. >> He's a drama YouTuber, isn't he? He does
a bunch of like that. >> Does some drama stuff. Yeah. Does
some drama stuff. Yeah. >> Then what what was meaningful?
>> What was meaning? Oh, you said he's a YouTuber. Does
commentary in his videos. So, he's a commentary YouTuber. I would
just say it's >> No, I'm saying the distinction, this argument
is not meaningful. It doesn't
>> Okay. All right. Sounds good. Anyway, so what was I
doing? Oh, that's why I was going to watch all the Smug Bug stuff,
though, cuz Aiko is now going after Smug >> It's got to
have more information. >> Calling me pedantic yesterday,
whatever it was.
>> Uh, Revoked, thank you for that comment. I would pretend
that it was Kelly, but I can see you making the content, so thank
you, Revoked, for giving Kelly an argument to make. I was just
agreeing with him.